let's jump with this we'll jump to the
story then we have this from washington
times trump ally rep scott perry says
fbi seized his cell phone
one day after the raid on former
president donald trump the fbi has
seized the cell phone of a republican
member of congress rep scott perry
pennsylvania republican said in a
statement to fox news that three fbi
agents handed him a warrant and demanded
his phone quote
this morning while traveling with my
family three fbi agents visited me and
seized my cell phone they made no
attempt to contact my lawyer who would
have made arrangements for them to have
my phone if that was their wish i'm
outraged though not surprised that under
the fb that under the f that the fbi
under the direction of merrick garland's
doj would seize the phone of a sitting
member of congress mr perry's statement
did not elaborate on whether he was told
anything about what the fbi was seeking
on the phone
mr perry is a founding member and
current chairman of the conservative
house freedom caucus
as a close ally of former president
donald trump the democrat appointed
january 6 panel has shown interest in
his communications with trump around
that time it's fascinating wasn't ron
desantis also one of the founders of the
freedom caucus i'm not sure questions
we're big fans of the freedom caucus we
are and i have to say this is not
surprising in the least but uh
man
look
when a story like this happens
it's kind of like oh wow that's bad
when steve bannon gets arrested you're
like oh wow that's bad
after the raid on donald trump's home
it's a it's a whole new territory now
now this is
a sitting member of congress had his
phone seized by the feds
yeah desantis did help start the freedom
caucus where we are right now is that
it's not former administration officials
it is current elected representatives
being targeted by the department of
justice
so where does this end so i remember you
talking about yeah of course he said it
all right take your drinks everyone so
tim talked about this situation where
there would be two cars driving
somewhere i don't remember the story it
was matt tybee matt tybee wrote this
really matt's ieb wrote i think it was
last october that's great
that we will get to the arrest that man
phase which sparks a civil war where you
will have two cars speeding towards a
police jurisdiction where the men will
jump out and point at each other arrest
that man is that where we are
we're beyond that we're you know so so
the question about that stuff is
will there be a fight over the
institution of law enforcement
democrats have weaponized it republicans
are too weak look i appreciate rick
santorum being on this show but he was
like no we got to follow the rules we
can't do this stuff it's like i'll see
in the gulag brother
i'm full abolish the fbi at this point
oh yeah yeah i mean it and that's the
reality it's like that i think in the
battle for law enforcement there's still
some constitution adhering awesome local
police officers sheriffs and communities
around the country
but the fbi and i'm not saying that
they're all about apples but my goodness
i mean the whole institution itself has
been robbed and is so centralized in
nature so i i people still have hope for
it i don't i think the only answer with
the fbi an institution that's as
nationalized and centralized as that at
this point is get rid of it we're in
like get reform a completely different
reality maybe not completely but but
relative to like 1970 when it was
wiretapping phones and it was a big deal
like when nixon got found to be
wiretapping the democratic whatever it
was the democrats during his campaign
or whatever um
now it's digital so much data is stored
digitally and for for these companies to
be what i'm calling the fbi a company
because it's kind of functioning like
its own
company uh is able to just like peruse
digital data and scrape
huge amounts of people's data uh
conversations and stuff it didn't exist
in 50 years ago so we maybe we do need
new
new rules and functions but the thing is
de facto whoever can do it is going to
do it so i saw uh
hassan [ __ ] tweeted you know you know
left wing guy he said something about
liking
watching steven crowder cry to to defund
the fbi or whatever and i'm like hasn't
crowder ragged on the fbi for a really
really long time yeah this isn't new
yeah no i mean you know so i'm like i
hear your brother hassan you know when
you're like cheering for steven crowder
talking about defunding the fbi and i'm
like many of us have been there for a
while now maybe maybe if you agree with
that
maybe there's like a caucus that can be
formed between progressives and
republicans where it's like okay we all
agree we're gonna get rid of that one
maybe the atf while we're at it i mean
they don't like the government right
supposedly so how about we all just say
uh you know um
abolish many of these
doj dhs institutions huh how about that
i'm all in for getting rid of the
three-letter agencies i think it's time
you look at their track record i'm a big
like that you can tell a tree by the
fruit and the fruit of the fbi has been
nothing but tyranny that seems very
corporate in nature for the last two
three decades and this goes all the way
back to you're right the 70s um and even
i would argue even further than that but
the fbi is an institution the cia is an
institution
um that
has such uh political agenda to it that
it's impossible to claim that they're
biased and that's you even had people
today
um like andrew yang that was calling
that out that was willing to admit that
like this looks political in nature and
so when people's immediate de facto
response at this point is like oh
there's the fbi being political again
like that's a sign that the tree is
rotten the fruit's rotten this thing
needs to just be uprooted
yeah 100 this is the first time i've
ever retweeted andrew cuomo because he
was honest quicker than some of these
republicans same for andrew yang but you
know why he was on it okay first he's
worried right yes
i will first say
i can respect that uh cuomo came out and
said the right thing right i will give
him credit for that
i will then add maybe the guy who killed
15 000 people by putting covet patients
in nursing homes might be a little
worried about what the government's
going to do when they go after
politicians he's sitting in his living
room and he sees the news and he goes
wait we're doing that now i thought we
were off limits no no no no no we gotta
yeah yeah yeah when it comes for you man
that's the problem with the
weaponization of all this stuff but uh
i don't know i i don't i don't know how
the republicans
i don't know what the republicans would
even do kevin mccarthy's acting like
he's like mark your calendar merrick
garland because when we get in in
november we're gonna send you more
sternly worded letters while you
continually destroy this country i don't
understand why
what like worst case scenario or even
just like normal case scenario if trump
were to get elected again and to get an
office like what would be what would be
that
they're gonna fire him maybe maybe
people will get fired maybe that's what
this is about but like really the threat
of our country is not there there's no
like oh maybe something is going to
devastate like we're okay it's the
economy is bad and we need to fix the
economy regardless of who's the power
the bureaucratic state has been in power
for too long and they will not let an
elected official remove them from power
there is this parasitic entity that is
the bureaucratic state latched onto our
country suckling away and controlling it
like a brain slug and donald trump is
trying to remove it but it's almost
impossible it is resisting
these people aren't elected they get
appointed they stay in through numerous
administrations the civil servants so i
have to we've talked about on the show
you know president gets in the gets in
office they're like i'm gonna uh get the
troops out of the middle east and then a
bunch of documents then they're dead on
the desk and they say no you're gonna
bomb this guy this guy and this guy he
goes
i'm gonna blow up kids and that's
exactly what happens so when donald
trump gets in this is my theory my
hypothesis
they say okay mr president you're the
president fine boom they slam the files
on the desk this is our agenda this is
what we do and he goes
no no we're not doing any of that that's
stupid i don't know i don't know why you
want to do that and then they start
saying no you don't understand like we
are the cia
like we do these things this is what
we're doing and why because don't know
don't care how does it help america
and they're like okay we got to stop
this guy
i think there was a point
before trump got elected he had a
meeting with a bunch of like
establishment figures i was in dc for
apparently he was like in a building
somewhere
and i bet they were like if you win will
you play ball and he said if i win i'm
the president and we're gonna do what
america wants
and then i think these people were like
okay that's it he can't win he can't be
allowed to win yeah so i'll give you a
real rule i'll give you an example our
our middle eastern agenda i talk about
it often the qatar turkey pipeline we
had a
multi-presidential agenda doesn't matter
who the president is we were doing this
building these pipelines trying to get
energy into europe competing with russia
donald trump comes in and goes no excuse
me no and he shuts it all down
shut down the tpp too
oh that was like kicking them into balls
so they're shrieking
now donald trump says i'm gonna fire all
of them schedule f and they're just
losing their minds
so this is what you get when you have
unelected bureaucrats who actually run
your country
ray signed off on this little people are
saying okay i want to pretend to know
what was going on in the inner workings
of this
but this they they know what they're
doing
they are trying to stop someone from
being able to become the duly elected
president for a second this is also like
you don't this is kennedy he came out he
was like i'm gonna break up the cia and
then kennedy got assassinated like you
don't threaten the cia if you're gonna
fire people you just do it when you have
the ability to do it let me you know
like tell them all ahead of time you're
gonna do it well let me ask you like do
you know what the if like why leave
why what was the motivation of lee
harvey oswald um
yeah what the origin the actual story is
like what's the what what what an angry
communist fidel castro sympathizer and
he didn't like kennedy yeah
i mean that maybe i guess that's the
story yeah it's a story but he was
working with groups that were i think
what happened was he loaned a group of
radicals as gun and then they placed
they they killed kennedy and put his gun
in the building well didn't kennedy want
to get us stopped vietnam or something
like that
yeah he was a pretty anti-war guy in
general why would he escalate he was
actually escalating vietnam he was us
yeah but he but he had always said that
there was a power greater than him that
was manufacturing a lot of the crises
that were happening remember he was like
there's that famous quote that
kennedy was basically saying that i'm
not fully the one in charge here there's
a whole different thing happening behind
the curtain and and then obviously he's
taken out also he and his brother bobby
went hard on the mob hard on the mob
yeah so they think maybe the mob was
involved in killing him thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you